[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre 7,8
choisir tout de suite les titres de ce
nouveau numéro
cette semaine c'est la fête des
possibles à saint-quentin-en-yvelines 25
associations se sont regroupées pour
vous la faire vivre samedi à montigny le
bretonneux et guyancourt et dimanche au
verger des habitants de saint rémy les
chevreuse hervé lignol et agneaux blasé
seront avec nous pour présenter les
animations pour débuter sa saison
l'espace philippe noiret des clis ou a
misé sur le cinéma
l'exposition trucages et très cinéma du
collectionneur bruno bouchard commence
samedi et dévoile les meilleurs
accessoires des plus grands films
on y joue l'été autour du barbecue mais
aussi en club la pétanque est un sport
qui compte plus de 300 mille dix ans y
est nous sommes allés rencontrer
l'équipe féminine du club de montigny le
bretonneux en plein entraînement pour le
championnat régional
l'espace philippe noiret des
clayes-sous-bois entame sa saison avec
une exposition sur le cinéma pour une
eau bouchard est passionné de près
cinéma cette époque avant les frères
lumière il en est même collectionneur
mais sa rencontre avec andré pierre del
accessoiristes rue kyste et spécialiste
des effets spéciaux va l'amener à
étendant sa collection jacques tati
alain delon et encore jean paul belmondo
il a travaillé entre 1947 et 1983 avec
les plus grands noms du cinéma
surnommé le petit homme vert il confie
ses cartons à bruno bouchard qui en fait
des expositions pour lui rendre hommage
l'exposition trucages et pré cinéma
s'ouvre au public samedi 22 septembre et
se tiendra jusqu'au 17 octobre
il y aura un jour de fête et vacances de
monsieur hulot playtime et il a fait
voilà presque de son film où il a tourné
avec les plus grands enfin real les
acteurs et il y aura par thématique par
film des accessoires comme le magnifique
peur sur la ville enfants d
des films qui ont marqué un peu
d'histoire du cinéma on va trouver son
voile à des fausses cartes d'identité de
d'acteurs des faux lingots des faux
billets des bouteilles entre la vraie la
faute ça va être vraiment comme jeudi un
joyeux bordel et aura aussi son fonds
photographique
voilà on le voit avec gabin alagna 70 70
photos et depuis le 15 septembre c'est
la fête des possibles à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines vingt cinq
associations se sont réunies pour me
faire vivre en concentrant ses
animations sur ce week end avec notament
yao blasonnés de l'association artisans
du monde et hervé lignol de
l'association sky en transition bonjour
bon alors tous les deux vous représentez
un collectif tout d'abord est ce que
vous pouvez m'expliquer le principe de
cette fête des possibles alors oui c'est
un événement national qui vise à mettre
en avant toutes les initiatives de
transition écologique en france avec ben
saint quentin un collectif de 25
associations qui ont été réunis par
artisans du monde qui nous a mis autour
d'une table pour organiser
la chose et faire vivre ça sur le
territoire de 50 ans alors justement
cette 25 ans association c'est quand
même une sacrée organisation surtout
qu'au début vous étiez que quatre en
2016 comment ça a pu évoluer comme ça et
bien l'urgence du dérèglement climatique
a dû faire prendre conscience à pas mal
de gens qu'il faut faire quelque chose
et sur le plan local il existait déjà
l'an dernier il y avait une dizaine
d'associations
petit à petit on a pris contact les uns
avec les autres et je crois que
l'investissement personnel des bénévoles
parce que ce sont des petites
associations qui n'ont ni subvention ni
locales souvent se sont rencontrés
autour de thématiques qui nous
paraissent très important donc est-ce
que vous m'expliquer un peu qu'est ce
qu'on va pouvoir retrouver ce week-end
alors y avoir trois sortes d'animations
on va avoir de la pédagogie avec des
jeux on va avoir des ateliers pratiques
où les gens vont pouvoir faire avec
leurs mains et puis des présentations de
projets plus ou moins grand sur sur
saint quentin
alors si vous voulez je peux vous citer
deux trois exemples dans chacune des
catégories sur ce qui est des jeux par
exemple et de la pédagogie va y avoir un
un jeu qui va montrer les différentes
étapes de la production de la viande et
ses conséquences pour l'homme et
l'environnement va y avoir dans le
quartier des garennes un jeu de l'oie
géant sur l'énergie qui va en essayer de
susciter des questionnements auprès des
habitants va y avoir artisans du monde
qui fera quelque chose qui doivent
tenter de faire découvrir la différence
entre commerce équitable et le commerce
dominant et bien entendu tout l'intérêt
de feu du commerce équitable dans les
ateliers va y avoir des bacs
l'incroyable comestible par exemple
aux garennes va y avoir une
démonstration de machines de tissage
également dans le quartier des gares end
et partage de savoir-faire au pas du lac
1re et par vélo aux garennes
et puis la promotion de logiciels libres
par exemple je suis maire sur le vélo il
ya une balade à vélo au syli à un grand
circuit
les gens vont pouvoir faire en fait le
lien parce que nos associations sont
aussi beaucoup dans lien entre les gens
entre les habitants du territoire
et là ce sera le lien entre les
différentes animations dans les
différents quartiers
asud canal au pas du lac près de
l'université
voilà un grand parcours de deux heures
je crois et nous vous m'expliquez chaque
association à un pool un stand pour
qu'on puisse découvrir toutes les
associations on se regroupe un petit peu
par thème mam est simplement là où on
pensait que chacun serait le mieux mises
en valeur
on se regroupe aussi pour ne pas faire
double emploi
un même endroit par exemple moi je suis
au pas de blague parce que je sais que
au sud canal il y à une animation qui
est assez semblable à celle que je vais
proposer aux enfants
donc c'est un petit on a fait comme on a
pu donc on s'est organisé entre nous
démocratiquement voilà parce que 25
associations faut quand même que chacun
y trouve son compte puis savoir l'espace
qui le souhaitent
d'accord donc on est quatre à un endroit
sain qu'un autre 3 un autre est
justement le tour de vélo par permettra
à voir tout sinon ça donne la liberté h
aux gens qui en moins de temps d'aller
qu'un ou deux endroits on leur donnera à
chaque endroit à l'information avec un
petit plan pour qu'ils puissent être au
courant et je puisse choisir selon leurs
envies le temps totti dispose ludique
ludique et ça s'adresse à qui alors qui
c'est qui peut venir s'adresse vraiment
à tout le monde alors on invite vraiment
les gens de toute la social de tout âge
c'est vraiment ouvert à tout le monde
parce que il ya tous les sujets et les
gens peuvent avoir envie de s'engager
dans des choses plus ou moins difficiles
plus ou moins à leur portée et tout le
monde est invité il ya des choses pour
les enfants pour des trentenaires et
puis aussi des retraités
donc on vous invite à sortir du
quotidien si vous voulez un peu de
positif voire des projets positifs ont
vraiment on va donner de l' envie aux
gens est d'accord donc merci hervé ligne
l'état niasse au blaise n'est pour tous
ces informations donc pour le plus de
renseignements sur les différentes
animations ce sera sur le site internet
fait des possibles wiggins sky est et
puis il différent page facebook qui
existe j'ai vu que ce qui pousse toutes
les pages facebook c'est bonjour merci
vous êtes venu sur notre plateau merci
beaucoup et on vous retrouve ce week end
alors merci autres sorties culturelles
vous attendent ce week end l'estival de
son festival de saint germain en laye
commence vendredi
depuis 30 ans le festival dédié à la
musique francophone nous fait découvrir
des artistes émergents
cette année ils sont plus de trente à
écouter jusqu'au 6 octobre un spectacle
original et poétique à la mairie de
trappes lorraine bihorel de la compagnie
sable d'avril met en image des comptes
avec du sable
nouveauté cette année à la brise un
goûter en présence de l'artiste est
proposée à la suite de la représentation
des rêves dans le sable est à voir à 15
heures dès l'âge de 7 ans la france
s'est illustrée en pétanque en devenant
championne du monde face au maroc le
week-end dernier
379 français pratiquent ce sport en club
et à montigny le bretonneux elles sont
dix femmes dont 6 forme d'une équipe
pour le championnat interclubs
nous les avons rencontrés en plein
entraînement
la pétanque c'est aussi une affaire de
femmes dans le club de montigny le
bretonneux
c'est du sérieux versée aujourd'hui
enfin comme en compétition
c'est l'exercice de tir de précision
là on va jouer contre toute la région
ile de france
après c'est pour ça qu'on a promis
remplace un coach pour qu'ils puissent
nous aider à monter et à progresser
l'équipe féminine a remporté le
championnat interclubs des yvelines de
elles sont qualifiées pour la deuxième
division régionale il fallait donc
passer à la vitesse supérieure pour
cette année 2010 8
elles se sont très vite très bien
entendu et le fait qu'il y ait quelqu'un
qui vienne un petit peu on va dire les
coachs et entre guillemets au départ
cela a fait du bien on leur donnait des
conseils au départ juste comme ça mais
qu'après bas m'ont appelé coach alors
donc je suis dit allez hop on va
s'occuper d'elle et pour aller le plus
loin possible l'équipe à sa botte
secrète
la benjamine de l'équipe à 19 ans elle a
terminé vice championne départementale
en tête à tête l'année dernière ce qui
lui a valu le titre de meilleur espoir
féminin de la ville de montigny le
bretonneux parler puis vint la rencontre
d'anciens amis puis lui joue à la
pétanque au premier rendez vous de ce
championnat interclubs régional pour les
femmes le 29 septembre
elles affronteront l'équipe de mesnil
droit et les inscriptions au club de la
smb pétanque de montigny le bretonneux
sont toujours possibles
renseignements sur le site de
l'association sportive nouveau rendez
vous dans votre 7,8 loisirs on dépasse
les frontières yvelinoise cette semaine
direction la galerie sakura de paris à
la découverte de l'exposition lost in
space 30 artistes pour plus de 150
oeuvres sur le thème du cosmos le tout
sur le ton de l'humour et de la
réflexion
reportage de nicolas le herissier de nos
confrères via grand paris un chat
portant un scaphandre une fusée
dégageant une fumée rose un bol rempli
de planètes ou encore des jeunes femmes
en combinaison de cosmonaute
embarquez pour un voyage aux confins de
l'univers mêlant humour et vision du
futur l'exposition lost in space à la
galerie sa cure à met en lumière une
centaine d'oeuvres d'artistes
contemporains du monde entier
leur but c'est de casser les codes il
propose des choses très décalé qui
sortent de l'ordinaire et nous ça nous
plaît du coup vous avez à la fois du
portrait du paysage la couleur par
exemple qu'on a deux artistes parisiens
de photographes qu'ils ont décidé de
détourner des vraies photos la nasa en
apportant petit twist féminin en
remplaçant toutes les têtes d'hommes par
les têtes de femme vous avez la foi de
la photo mais aussi des illustrations 3d
donc c'est très varié et vous avez à peu
près une trentaine d'artistes en ce
moment qu'ils ont travaillé sur le thème
de l'espace si la conquête spatiale et
la science-fiction inspire beaucoup les
cinéaste et romancier il en est de même
pour tous les artistes exposés ici
souvent décalé et intrigante la galerie
nous invite à réfléchir sur l'avenir du
monde où les cosmonautes prendront le
temps de faire des selphy et iront
coloniser la planète mars
on trouve aussi plusieurs clins d'oeil à
des personnages célèbres de bande
dessinée juste derrière moi on a deux
oeuvres signées par l'artiste turc si
hanouna lan qui avait déjà participé à
nos et claude précédente sur star wars
sur les super héroïne etc
et là elle a décidé de mettre en scène
des personnages qu'on connaît toutes et
tous de la bande dessinée tintin et
capitaine haddock et son but c'était de
encore une fois apporté un petit twist
spatiale avec le capitaine haddock qui
regardent avec les étoiles pleins pleins
les yeux des bouteilles de whisky en
apesanteur est juste là en à tintin et
son fidèle chien milou avec un os dans
la bouche
si une oeuvre vous plaît il vous sera
possible de l'acquérir
vous avez jusqu'au 22 septembre pour en
profiter c'est la fin de votre magazine
loisirs merci de nous avoir suivis et
rendez vous la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro
m
oui
oh
[Musique]
nous